republican congressman adam kinzinger is
lashing out at republican congresswoman
lauren bobert remember that lauren
bobert recently said i'm sick and tired
of this separation of church and state
it's kind of the constitution lauren but
you're tired of it adam kinzinger
calling it the christian taliban as a
reminder here is the clip from a couple
of days ago
lauren beaubert going full three
theocracy saying
church and state i'm sick of it the
reason we had so many over-reaching
regulations in our nation is because the
church complied right
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church that is
not how our founding fathers intended it
and i'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
constitution it was in a stinking letter
and it means nothing like what they say
it does
[Music]
whoa
well it turns out that that is crazy and
fellow republican launching a civil war
salvo from within the republican party
adam kinzinger says quote there is no
difference between this
this meaning you know this video of
lauren bober that we just watched
there's no difference between this
and the taliban we must oppose
the christian taliban
i say this as a christian
has a republican politician
straight up said christian taliban
before because they love to talk about
sharia law
and oh it's bad and it's gonna it's
coming and
hold on a second
the christian version of sharia law it
was what has actually been plaguing this
country for a very long time i disagree
with adam kinzinger politically but i
have some respect for him now i know
it's easier to put country over party
the way that he's doing when you're
leaving i understand that i'm not naive
i get it he's in a position where he
doesn't care because he's leaving
but it is amazing how the bar has been
lowered democrats today
would be thrilled to some degree to deal
with the republicans from 15 years ago
not that those were good people we
shouldn't see them as good people
but 15 years ago
the republicans were much more
reasonable to deal with that being said
the republicans of 15 years ago
are responsible for
the republican party today being what it
is and what i mean by that is
they didn't condemn
the start
of the rhetoric that led to trumpism
today they didn't condemn the extremism
they didn't say well we've got to stop
this here or here or here they allowed
it to keep going
so while i would much rather be dealing
with the republicans of 15 years ago
than people like lauren bobert that's
for sure
we also have to understand the
historical context which i talked about
with many people including noam chomsky
on the show before
that they are also responsible for what
we are seeing today but to the extent
that adam kinzinger is willing to call
it out to the extent that adam kinzinger
is maybe going to change some
republicans mind and get some republican
to go hey you know what
the bobert
version of republicanism is crazy
it's not even constitutional tired of
separation of church and state it's like
being tired of the first amendment
lauren which i thought you cared about
um to the extent that he might have an
impact on anybody i gladly welcome adam
kinzinger's comments
i never have time to read all of the
non-fiction books that i want to read
our sponsor blinkist has solved the
problem for me in a way because blinkist
takes thousands of the best and newest
non-fiction books extracts the key
takeaways and then you can either read
or listen to them in 15 minutes i read
all the time i love narrative nonfiction
i read economics i read all these
different things as i said before i
would love to have time to read more
history i just don't right now
especially with a newborn you should see
what's going on in the middle of the
night but
uh with blinkist i was able to read in
fact i listened to a 15-minute audio
version of putin's people by katherine
belton with what's going on in ukraine
and russia i just wanted more history
how did uh in fact the book is called
how the kgb
took back russia and then took on the
west i wanted to learn how did this
adversarial situation develop
what is the history of the putin kgb
coming to power etc i did not have time
to read that book in full but in just 15
minutes with blinkist i was able to get
all of the uh key points which now i can
use when i am talking about ukraine and
russia and have more context blinkist
has condensed over 5000 non-fiction
books in 27 categories try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a
subscription at blinkist.com pacman the
link is down below